哇 今天台灣股市上漲214.7千保運站成功
可是4萬點會不會再跌破
還有
莫德納爆漲176%
等於100塊馬上漲到276塊
欸 市值
增加一兆
一天增加一兆
AI下個關鍵視察
是不是則則說的 殘身不老 已經不是夢了
講殘身不老有點誇張
長命百歲 真的已經可能不是夢了
我都有獨家預告 你會發現我像預約家不像分機師
真的沒辦法胡扯
第三個 美國緊急回購 美債
資金會回流股市嗎
今天這三大重點 我一次讓我一次愛個購
讓我一次講個購
好 大好 我是某個投顧的投資長郭總分醫師
也是全台灣粉絲人數據桌的郭總投資長
郭總分醫師 可是我覺得我講的
有時候 與其說我當分醫師 我不喜歡
不如我當預言家 我比較喜歡當預言家
分醫師實在是我覺得不難擔 好不好 不難擔
不知道跟大家胡扯 昨天有沒有說結算建成責
今天拉起來對不對
我們說很多股票說不要去追高 你看
那精彩很像神經病
不要追高門啊 哇拉展庭又殺下去了
股票這樣子 跌停的時候又拉起來
現在股票好像很難做 也不會難做啊
為什麼不會難做 你看 比如說2344
華班電池這邊不行就又拉起來了
當然今天有一個族群特別弱勢
這這個國際怎麼看 我看五百多塊
閉眼睛買吧 AI就個趨勢
這時候實話實說,我很多東西我都預告在前面,為什麼說實話實說?
你們看一個股票就好了,接著股票大跌,為什麼開高走低
很簡單,你們看這新聞就知道了嘛,來來來
這邊
超微多單,Google啦,有沒有
聯發科警戒
是不是
超微就蘇制風 AMD 啊
蘇多丹什麼 TPU晶片有沒有到
超微多丹 Google
聯發科警戒有沒有
你看對不對
聯發科聽到這個消息被人家奪丹了
來我們來看一下
我們看一下所謂的外資
看一下看一下
賣隔離啦
賣給你啦
他不買自己買啦
他不買啊
叫你買啦
不買我沒有證據啦
可是叫你買啦
來 聯發科評價
麥格里罕3萬元給予優於大盤
他把20280 ASIC營收達400億美元
我那時候一直罵
有沒有 你會發現我認識
我不是分析師 我是預言家
這樣講我很誇張
可是我喜歡邏輯好的人跟我對話
我最討厭邏輯不好的人跟我對話
我都不想聽
沒有邏輯的事情你不要跟我講話
好不好
聯發科評價
那個1我要求比較完美一點
看今天畫面有沒有再幫我調一下
我覺得不太行
我覺得好 車圓
聯發科評價
賣隔離證券 喊三萬元給予優異大牌
沒有
2028年 現在這樣多少
1000幾年 2028年
叫2028年
你連明天台灣股市會崩盤都不知道了
你共產2020、2028年賣隔離證據
來來來
你不要說我私厚
我郭總在台灣私厚邊人家
我要是前面講在前面
你看一下
你會發現我預言家
來
看一下
起始再一次
請那個威漢以後 因為今天事要請假 我們找威漢來
我們年團隊隨便找一個 不是台大政大
就是分析 威漢以後要當分析師 是帥哥
好不好 但現在我這邊磨練
等到磨練成功 我也不會說從我這邊磨練
不需要 成功不必在我
不過威漢記得一下 要播重播的時候
多個前面幾秒
來 這個有時候我會跟他們講話
有時候跟你們講話
投資朋友我現在要跟你們講話
看一下我那時候傳播我怎麼罵
那些外資邏輯很差
我說明年的行情都不知道
明年行情都不知道 你給我後年
來 看一下
所以你說那個麥格里
跟我講說 後年
連發科的TPU晶片相關的一些營收
整個營收可以從EPS5、60塊
增加到EPS288有
我如果沒聽說的話
我聽到 把步啦
你看Google錢麻煩就馬上把TPU的晶片
都是TPU晶片
是
這是聯發科最近的進展設計
我就不用Colors了
你覺得後人一定會給聯發科嗎
不知道
不知道這是答案
不知道就不知道
不知為不知是不是
是不是 四隻也
不知道就不知道 他們專什麼知道
有些外資的邏輯都很錯誤
我問你啦 後人你怎麼知道
你明天怎麼知道你走到路上會不會怎麼樣
我不是在罵你啊 我想試試啊
你看 怎麼用後年EPS 怎麼用後年EPS
你看 你給我一萬塊的EPS 什麼EPS多少錢
用後年EPS 後年的本EPS 亂七八糟
我看我AI不代表聯發科 一定會賺到一萬元
會不會 可是你不能用後年EPS來說
又不是TPU金面職位它生產而已
我們講 關這個邏輯 你是不是要看我一輩子
廢話 你去問哪個外資
咱們分析師,外資分析師像可以幹30年
可以像我在股市30年
不要說30年,10年的外資分析師就很厲害了
邏輯,不好意思,這講到很嗆
請你告訴我邏輯還沒錯誤
重點是我事先預告
今天如果他沒有被搶單,丟臉是我
所以你們不用擔心
我看接下網路上留言說
哲哲,阿宏海怎麼不講
你們有時候看很短
宏海他就是EPS的20元
AI就是無眼佛界
等一下再跟人家莫德納做了什麼事情
你會發現起雞皮疙瘩
為什麼知道
因為AI的趨勢是對的
你看好連發科你不如看好記憶體
因為記憶體會求我好幾年
因為AI會越來越虛偶越來越大
你懂不懂
AI虛偶越來越大
我現在常常會念一些設計人員
機核人員
譬如說哇
這個一個報表做給我看
他們都做到生一個小時
我說你們都不用AI
我馬上生徒給大家看 三分鐘
我們騙你 設計圖案我也是一樣
都兩三分鐘 會用AI的人
比那些專業的人他不會用AI的人
會搶100倍
真的 真的 真的
我告訴大家 我現在超會找資料
因為我很喜歡問 而且我邏輯特好
我說真的 不是我給你湊美
關聯八科這個 你不覺得
你就在看我節目一輩子嗎
隨便告訴你 你看到外資的報告
看到新聞好像很厲害
賣隔離還1萬元的邏輯錯誤
2028年都不會被搶單
就獨佔了是不是
別人看我太封天
我叫他人看不穿
賣隔離的你也不要難過
反正大家不知道你是誰
我說真的啦
好不好
邏輯再訓練一下
來
來看一下
說我們看一下
我們來看一下大家來
給他打速,給他打速一下,含有沒有
我今天可以跟您講很多的股票,我股票很強,來我們看一下
能拿莫德納嗎?莫德納可以買喔,好高額
因為我,好不好,這則沒有看那麼短,對,這則沒有那麼短
你不要開玩笑,好不好,來來來
沒有他是生病的,利利生病的,好不好
不過我說真的啦,我覺得重點還是在我身上
你有沒有發現到我現在主持人後來比例越來越低
因為我覺得也不是每個人像我這樣工作款
我都不勉強別人 好不好
這跟大家講 來
他正生病 他正生病
確診了 確診了 COVID-19
其實我事前也有跟他講要去打疫苗
利用散半時間去打
可是他可能忘記了 沒有關係
講實在話 這個都不能勉強大家
就像我跟你講
我已經跟你講了喔
10年內基本上你就會發現到
人們會開始平均稅數會從賣相100歲喔
10年後應該10年後
我們賣相100歲
會賣相100歲喔
我很多預告是很恐怖的喔
我很多預告是很恐怖的
我為什麼說我很多預告很恐怖
今天就更恐怖的新聞來看一下
莫德納
等一下再講美國公司
再講美國公司的事情
莫德納疫苗大突破
威漢帥哥以後拜託不要有黑的畫面
拉滿拉滿
我在跟我們訓練分析師跟他講怎麼做節目
來 疫苗突破
爆展176% 怎麼樣爆展?
MRNA
我直接做一個AI圖
我們認出Ai圖不是
請AI做一張圖沒那麼簡單
來
呃
怎麼樣?診所有點錯字
診所mRNA的疫苗搭配KITRIDA
這什麼意思?這另外一家的藥物
好像是莫沙東的
莫德納的疫苗配合人家的莫沙東的藥物
去黑色塑流,就是皮膚癌
皮膚癌,尤其是那種最毒的皮膚癌
三期臨傳,就是高風險的
3期靈傳 基本上就是要拜拜了
反而怎麼樣 顯著降低手術後移症復發率
沒有復發了 為什麼 來
你們要長命百歲 拜託 加油
加油 把身體養好 好不好 來
你看我是不是說
癌症最麻煩是肺癌 我說肺癌很多種
或者是說很多 你皮膚癌很多種
每個人腫瘤都不太一樣 突變都不太一樣
所以他個人 他幫你各額能化
總流切除,再幫你基因定序
你要知道你的總流是哪一種基因
基因定序又怎麼樣?
AI篩選,你看我做這個圖非常漂亮
也是用AI做,但是資料也是要問清楚
做好AI篩選預測以後,怎麼樣?
選出怎麼樣?
從AI演算法的海量圖片數據中篩選
選出最34個關鍵圖片看源
你知道為什麼嗎?
你像比如說那個HP 就是凡菜花的
有沒有 就是HP疫苗又有四價的又有九價的
人家不會走一種 你懂不懂
好 都是一樣 所以但是又有點不太一樣
他選擇34個最關鍵的圖片看人
選擇34個總會中一個吧
然後呢 BMR、MRNA
MRNA是新的技術 所以疫苗會那麼快
那時候我說一年內就有疫苗
我就是抗MRNA 我就抗MRNA
我之前是他有醫生打掉人罵我
奇怪 我只是要查得比你多年幹嘛罵我
你懂不懂 他說要跟我信
那有疫苗跟我信 後來不見了
好多罵我 不在乎
我再跟你講一件事
真的人的證明10年過後
有機會賣相100歲
甚至5年過後開始賣相
你看這疫苗製造 個人化的疫苗製造
挑選三四個關鍵圖片有注射與T-C-Bow訓練
我們自己的T-C-Bow幫你殺
人類是最強的 你知道嗎
人都知道為什麼要激鬥訓練
為什麼要怎麼樣 防吃呆 看毛
你就自己打疫苗是觸發你的T-C-Bow
或者很多人你自己去殺那些病毒
T-C-Bow 都你是T-C-Bow有時候
T-C-Bow有時候是連自己人都殺了
你懂不懂
就要化療藥 全部都一起殺了
T細胞精準辨識,清楚癌細胞
我只殺你這個圖片的,你這個癌症而已
效果奇好啊
那以後可以做什麼?
以後可以做很多的癌症啊
腎臟癌,肺癌也有,現在已經做二期去了,現在三期去了
MRNA,還有什麼三中因子,那你變年輕了
這些都是AI的數據,以前會跑那麼快嗎?沒有
我問你一件事情
你有巴菲特假設你有巴菲特
你現在九十幾歲 你有一兆資產
跟我現在二十五歲 我有十萬塊
你要跟巴菲特交換身體嗎
不要
我管你有沒有一兆資產 沒錯吧
當然不要 快死了
我很崇拜他 我不希望他快死
你不會換
巴菲特也想跟你換 那你不會換
所以對巴菲特來講 他一兆要怎麼樣
我0月我花個1000億 我投資AI
如果人家長命百歲 那些有錢人想法都是一樣的
秦始皇為什麼跑去東營
為什麼 叫徐福去東營 有此一說
產生不老的藥 為什麼
有錢有時就要產生不老
所以告訴你現在已經是真的開始了
那今天這東西 莫德納一天長170%
你們剛才拍到一天斬一兆
這是真的題材啊
活生生的AI進步在前面
你們只看到
小鼻子小眼睛
他愛我 他不愛我
我的背鬥元件為什麼疊個兩塊三塊
I don't care啊
你看短的不要跟我來啊
我看長的你知道
我喜歡他預言家啦
我很不訊那些老頭顧分析師
我每天賺多少 我每天賺多少
我摸頭顧老師不一樣
我來跟你講這些東西的啦
我想說我是那種預言家
那酒用
這真的跟人家不一樣
很爽你知道嗎
雖然講話這樣很粗俗 很爽
你看不懂我的瑞智 我看
那節目實在太無聊了
有時候整個吼 吼很大聲
那都是表演
有時候只是要讓你記得這些東西
我再講一件事
來 我再給第二個預測
10年內
這是預測 不代表百分之百
好不好
我們這分析師沒有百分之百
我先跟你講
你要有百分之百你去找別人
我不做這個事情
主管機關也規定我們不能這樣講
可是我告訴你,我覺得有極大機率,10年內,
它整個是機效,可是我連你看醫療保健都很這樣跟你講,
所有風險我都跟你講,10年內我跟你講,
你們記得黨務存的,這樣黨務存的藥物,
或者PASCK9,就這樣黨務存的藥物,
會變成日常生活所需的必需品質,什麼意思?
越來越多的學說 越來越多的研究告訴你
膽固醇是這樣子 你人的扣打就是額度這麼高
你一開始可能出生的時候對不對
你第一病毒膽固醇如果是100以上 你就會增加很快
增加到這邊之後爆掉 你人生就是心血管疾病
就中風了 在這邊就心機葛聖 拜拜
腦中風就拜拜 心血管主色
中風在新戰就心血管主色
就是腦中 就是就是就是心臟中風
好不好 心臟病
這邊腦血管中風 就有可能眼睛或怎麼樣
再怎麼懂 好
膽固醇 低密度膽固醇
累積累積到這邊就爆炸
你懂我意思嗎 所以越低越好
以後一定有這種 人的額度就大概這樣子
增加到1T的程度 假設你低密度轉過程200以上
不好意思 你可以增加速度很快
你可能3幾歲的重風 拜拜
如果你低密度轉過程150 你可能是50歲
你比一半的快 你150比200的快
你可能是50歲的重風 200的低密度轉過程200的
你可能3級會中風
低密度膽固醇100以下的
甚至50以下 你增加很慢
就算到100歲你到這邊會贏
還沒到警戒點
到警戒點就爆炸了
我這邊第二個預告
相信我啦
可是你要長命百歲有癌症對不對
前提是三高致
彈尿病高血壓
好 什麼
還有膽固醇我跟你講這些
好不好
彈尿病膽固醇壓膽固醇
減肥之恩該打就打
好不好
因為減重後這三個都會下來
很多問題是減重
減重睡眠運動
基本上你們就長命百歲了
然後不要再金錢煩惱就長命百歲
要把生命變寬
懂不懂
反正你怎麼說不要死
所以不要玩太刺激的
我也是覺得不要滑雪
你們喜歡滑我會沒辦法
我已經告訴你怎麼長命百歲了
你們相信我我會當原家
我跟你講這些東西我都預告
好不好
OK嗎
講那健康題才會收會員嗎?
沒有收不到會員
我不在乎啊
我開心啦
我跟你講你看很多健康頻道
說不定還沒有我深入顯出
我告訴你 我騙你啦
我跟你講我已經跟你講
哪有人一直跟你講說會產命百歲的
A.I 我是第一個看到缺的QBT
我知道台灣股市要噴出去的
你可以來跟別人跟我PK啊
是不是
好不好
真的啦 好不好
直播95歲 好不好
財經系能賭嗎?
據股票的天分你們不要問我
對啊
我可以先研發出不會突頭的疫苗嗎?
我也希望我很怕我南天不能翹了
我這個沒有噴喔 好不好
來
這樣打過程要去哪裡買?
我不是醫生 你去問你
藥局其實都有賣啦
可是先給醫生看好不好
好不好
來
小心等你通通好 花一隻少一隻
不會嘛 再買就好
AI功課疫苗
折扯寶貝明天會噴嗎?
你們不要看那麼短 好不好
OK 來來
哲寶貝好多人問年電 你們都喜歡叫寶貝
看一下看一下
年電沒怎麼樣
你看這邊都打第二隻腳
我跟你講這邊股票很好
我跟你講勇者是我在這邊買最低檔
這一天不是我很多股票的一天
7月底的時候 7月29號30號那附近
買1150
勇者是我,這個是屬屬的練過,不要學,一般人做不到
厲害的人在這邊買
聰明的人在這邊買,或是這邊買
聽懂嗎?都一樣,差不多
怎麼懂?打第二隻腳確定打第二腳成功,或者反覆之後
在第二隻腳再確定打打體成功,不會破底
或是第二隻腳要下去的時候,這邊買
怎麼懂?現在這邊就可以買了
台灣國術,你們還聽不懂我剛才講的那些東西
我連,你們都聽不懂我還可以結論
我連麥格里證券寫的報告還一萬
他不是不能喊,他的邏輯有錯誤
我直接告訴他邏輯有錯誤
我說隨時會被搶單,不到一兩個月就被搶單了
這是我最恐怖的地方,這個很難預測
我都可以預測成功
台灣股市要到十萬點是非常好預測
因為隨著時間發展,血統或膨脹
隨著每家公司的EPS,平均EPS會增加
台灣股市十萬點是市債必行
已經只是問好如何怎麼去做而已
五年內很保守
四年內我已經說得很保守
我跟你講那是因為我是公開媒體的分析師
我告訴你
因為我是台灣最好的媒體的分析師
我跟你講四年內
甚至可能三年內都有可能
我們騙你
三年內十萬點你為什麼要小鼻子小眼睛
問我今天這些東西呢
不需要 我講都是稀優概念股
懂我會說什麼嗎
連這麼難預測的
還有我告訴你
AI會讓人家長命百歲
所以真的有了,你們去問所有的醫界人員
如果真的喜歡做研究的個人化的疫苗
這麼厲害,那是一個新的發展
那是一個很恐怖的發展,你知道嗎?
這有在做研究的醫生,拜託你們醫學人員
醫務人員,去看我剛講的那些東西好不好
你們也回答一下,這是非常恐怖的進步
你們就知道我差多少,跟別人差多少
這不是我的專產,我只喜歡預測未來
所以這些不是我專產的醫療
或者外資賣隔離,你可以邏輯業內會不會被搶單
我不用去問聯發科的高層經理、副總
你們會不會被搶單,他們自己不知道
可是我可以說他們也有可能被搶單
那TPU金面有沒有很難做
旁觀者清,色系才最難預測的
我都預測成功了,你不要跟我小比例小一點
就是為5萬點
應該說應該就是為5萬點
家可以應該
遲早的啦
今年真的會啦
遲早的
一切一切遇到前面
我也可以每天跟你講賺到錢
3374你不要我像老頭顧跟你講的東西
我順便喝個水
講機效
我機效今年機效很厲害
來
1 1
1 1動能的
1 1幫我
講一下這個簡訊
我們今天恭喜你
先開盤就暫停的來
好 8月20號禮拜四今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精彩股價開高噴出
一開盤就鎖上漲停
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺69%
我持續看好他
手上之骨破例預報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
來 讓他錢
讓他錢 所以OK
來 暫停
暫停再暫停
是不是 當我還說什麼 節目很精彩 醫療的那些
你們想到有個分析師提了跟你們講
你們有機會產品百歲 不覺得很開心嗎
把三高致好 為什麼 不能談到病結痴
你說腿還可以展出來吧 是不是 OK嗎
來 護士都變機器人 這我不知道 好吧
來 買國具 我不信十萬點 你不信
來說我最想粉絲 我看10萬頂 遲早的事好不好
何時而已 怎麼會不是 你連如果10萬頂都不懂
你就不知道怎麼叫通貨膨脹 何時而已 好不好
遲早的事何時而已 好不好
那10萬頂不代表你一定會賺錢 最後兩碼的事情
一堆自己的碗筋不要一直說好話
你在說我嗎 這些都是 我真的不好意思
這個不是玩君好不好 我能買到140萬
那我也真的很有錢 本來就有錢 花這種錢
其實都不用跟一些人廢話 直接封鎖他就好
他們都說你們是玩君
記錄者則 討厭者則 直接跟我們對做
像男人一般一樣好不好 OK
來 有人聽得不會在那邊打字
這什麼我不懂 不要管 聽到噴豬是粉絲好嗎
你們竟然跳好快 凱果準備串新高
來 分享航運的看法
我的重點還是AI
航運股像跟AI串不上邊
AI 知道嗎
不想看就走 對沒錯啦
不想看就走 不要浪費時間
我不是財經過 我不是其他網紅
我不是要靠爭論來的
就是準不準可以 不要廢話那麼多
不喜歡就對做就好了
趕快離開我市場 趕快離開我的頻道
紅道直播的時候越來越多傳媒 真的好多人
中美金怎麼噴的 我說過中美金兩倍 人家都很委屈
現在一堆股票委屈 你們進來到時候你們都說
這實在厲害 我管我 你不用管我厲害
我本來就厲害 你真的不要管我 你不用管我生死
拜託 你們賺錢好不好 你們賺錢比我賺錢還重要
真的 我沒有很在乎錢
我已經告訴我人生就是要去22台 去5車了
我現在慢慢的 慢慢的 慢慢的 慢慢的在賣相了
已經要賣一下第三台了
是不是?因為我在四萬年買很漂亮
三萬九千年買
好不好?這跟大家講
好不好?OK嗎?
以AI辦理開窮
這我不知道
我不知道事情我不知道
不跟你講
好不好?來
有沒有莫德達相干類股?
台灣的莫德達
台灣生技股都是
都是籌碼戰而已
所以為什麼不講台灣生技股?
那是看公司派高層有沒有拉
公司派主力要不要拉而已
基本上我不買
好不好?來
有排分析師,我不當分析師,我看應該300萬吧,訂閱吧
因為就不會有很多限制,但我覺得被限制也沒什麼不好
被規定也沒什麼不好
來,來,來,來,來,我加入會員有賺錢
應該之前加入,最近會員普普通通的,真的不好意思
我都講話很實在,好不好
習慣帥哥哲的自信,詐騙集團的績效都沒你好
當然詐騙機械機械是假的 好不好
就些老頭顧一樣 我每天想賺錢
到底有沒有買 沒買
好不好 來
我真的分析資源機能
資源我是賭以後的ASIC
這個有點到AI的誤會了
所以我股價比較差 真的不好意思
我比較少講資源機能
那時候就看到線情很漂亮
可是不代表他會死 沒展
我就不追高 你懂不懂
不追高 好不好 OK
來 我是折磅玩具
活那麼久沒錢會很可憐 賺錢比較實在啦好不好
還是要強調還是
整個是連續三年都在相對低一點 跌崩盤四五千點在附近的時候
雜幾千萬甚至雜一億的男人
連續三年都在相對低一點很漂亮
這個都是有新聞可考 有節目可以看的
你還覺得我是一般人 你實在太遜了
還有我剛才講這個東西 我沒想到大安博學很厲害
就是那個TPU晶片那個麥克里的邏輯出物
還是你們覺得這個預測很強
預測對了很正常
去年啦好不好
拉一下啦 去年是早就噴出去的啦
好不好 這跟大家講
好不好 來來
看大家有沒有回應 看一下大家有沒有回應
現在大家 我要變速讀你知道
則是檢頭法 是啊
他有人說我戴假髮
是檢頭法 假髮不會是短髮
有這種假髮嗎
有這麼素起來的假髮嗎?沒有啦
來來 蛇寶君
好啦好啦 我們不要去
也 那些人 對啦
謝謝你們一直罵那些無聊人
可是不要理他們 直接封鎖就好
我剛才把聯電換成兩酒精 換酒精不錯啦
黃小金是不是昨天 我看黃小金看K線
前幾天暫停又殺下去 昨天變疊
你不覺得黃小金跟精彩
這阻力 還是都有看我節目我不知道
我們是震盪洗盤的,開高走低拉起來
黃陽君一樣一千元以下就是不會啦
買啦真的啦
到時候細菌會很缺
這時候你的花呢?
昨天的花,時間結構了好不好
來,這時候會扣分嗎?
你說我們講過會不會扣分?
我可能有講過可能沒講過
你真的醫學常常是
大概兩三千年以前的時候看好不好
想請問腦Ai怎麼看
來啦 紅癌是會20塊啦
紅癌是20塊啦好不好
還是有機會20塊
20塊 現在很多人是不相信變現
來 莫德納給我非常大的信心
證明AI真的可以長命百歲
AI可以影響以後的製程
你們說工業所有的東西
你知道基本上我現在什麼事情我都會AI
我很多叫我們公司行政或研究員做事情
有時候看不下去我就做好賣
我做都比他們快
我直接問 因為我很會問 你知道嗎
真的我跟你講 會用AI的人
真的是以一擋百 我騙你 這是以一擋百
現在我跟你講 八卦 現在卻GPT比GPT強很多
就是卻GPT比Google的GPT強很多
所以會增差很多 卻GPT智力大增
哪個分析師跟你講這個東西
沒有啦 比一下投股很多更不會用
他們跟不會用A、A幫我解隔盤、幫我怎樣或怎樣
他們幫我選個標股
他們都是最出錢的
他們不知道那個差別
只有我知道 因為我每天在比較
你懂不懂 我每天在去看
問問題 你懂不懂
因為你把紅色丟了
如果以波動性來講
長得快慢而已的話
那你可以把它換掉
你可以把它換掉 你知道嗎
好不好
所以太紅了小心被針對
差點被針對
沒關係 我覺得
我沒有刻意對不起會研究
我是分析師我投資顧問
有賺有賠
我不會去跟你說跟主力配
我不去做這種事情
而且我選到大量的股票
是不是
這有罵星星
被別的分析是影響
你看被影響你是有可能賣70塊
現在1000多
哇 100多塊等下70塊
覺得我是混蛋
誰是混蛋
那些影響你的分析才是
才是最過分的
不是嗎
是不是?你看那個其他的分析師本來有些跟我和解
有一個不跟我和解的
跟我和解我就沒事 我也不想
我其實說我人很好 不跟我和解的
搞到最後連律師費都省
要告我親自出庭
親自出庭
然後連個律師都不請 省錢省的這樣子
我才不管他 我就是律師費 我照花
我就這種人
然後搞到自己身體不好 你們都知道誰
是不是?某一位姓張的分析師
高生你不好,我也覺得難過你會逼呢
你因為你抽到的就覺得郭忠是軟柿子
我就不適合這樣去打聽,你就不理我
是不是很氣還是很氣
那時候打開手機都一堆回報我的文章
還算是就這樣子
搞業績也不好,身體也不好,還是祝福他
成員了
來,帥哥哲我捷號
你捷號只聽老婆,現在只聽你的,準備離婚
你們不要這樣子,我們可以一起生我
來來,不要亂換股啦,台獨我不講政治
為什麼?你現在人是不是喜歡立即定,紅外轉國際
我覺得紅外轉國際這次不錯,富貴險中求啦
非洲人見到時候還是會缺,只是會缺那麼多
我跟你講你1200的國際我不敢想,800的國際我覺得有機會
這次殺下去,華星哥好不容易殺下去,我就OK
不要追漲 昨天華晶哥看來一副要斬平 一定要殺下去
但今天就可以 明天就可以考慮買了
我跟你講 這根本沒有反彈多少
產品30% 20% 可以買 可以買 真的
沒有那麼差啦 自然殺融資 殺儲治股 是不是
莫德納這一個東西 讓我對AI更有信心
以後會是AI醫療
你說 對 對 對 因為要我說
我覺得你們可以買那個 譬如說
美國生技ETF
如果你們要賭的話 我覺得美國生意醫部可以賭喔
欸欸欸 來來來
不講了 我自己想去買一下美國生技ETF
台灣有美國生技ETF
就直接買美國生技
不要買台灣生技ETF
台灣生技股可能會一起拉
對 以後開始會炒美國生技ETF
因為會不止莫德納 很多公司開始埃政制好了
之前時候會很多公司開始埃政可以制好了
我跟你講這三到五年內會很多
好不好
那都是AI造成的
記住我講的是美國升級ETF
你就不要壓迫一個家公司
為什麼?
因為ETF好處就是這家公司拜拜了
還可以買別家公司
你懂不懂?
這就是為什麼我推薦台灣50勝過推薦台積電
我對你們很好
台積電應該毅力不搖
但是Bertz有Bertz怎麼辦?
Bertz怎麼辦?
但是怎麼辦?
台積電不行怎麼辦?
你要別的股票
所以買台灣50比較
我都是風險百第一,沒有人像我這樣子
你們講台灣50,人家說到會員,不行
怎麼看AI跟私募基金的錢會被爆掉,引發金融海報
問題還是回到,你們還是聽不懂
AI跟私募基金借錢,或者現在瓦發行投資型公司在
他不是發行投資型公司在嗎?
利率變很高,然後造成美國公司在責力也高嗎?
然後美國公司在責力也很高,那是不是吸引股市資金
造成自己連股市的崩盤嗎?
前幾年股市崩盤
那動靈回來,AI可不可以賺錢?
我就回答問題的問題,我生計股我就想投資了
我是8倍,如果真的可以確定我成名百歲
為什麼不能丟個100億?
那些有錢很多,你知道現在的問題是
我記得其實90%幾的資產,全世界80%90%幾的資產
我聽到之前有一個研究,具在1%的人生上
那些有錢的願意把錢套出來就不一樣了
OK嗎?這時候我穿上看你的台
這台假的你不要拆我的台好不好
全部20年了怎麼樣?OK
只要堪配完全就是主力要不要拉而由
不講這種國票 不好意思
而且這邊主力很厲害 一直拆一拆
問完遊戲 講多了不要得罪好不好
有時候講話已經很實在了
我不可以得罪人好不好
我不認識別家投顧爺爺了
你們不要講自己的 畫面怎麼
聽好 你們不要攻擊哲哲 我也不會怎麼樣 我也不會攻擊你
你一直要攻擊我 我人人 攻擊太過分 一定回擊
回擊到你覺得很煩 好不好 OK
但你也不會故意再主動攻擊 可是回擊到
你另外也覺得 真的不要對哲哲做這種事 真的 好不好
OK 所以我不想講康佩特的壞話 我只能說那邊
這個裡面的主力 不是我所能了解的
我就不碰他 就這樣 OK
來
來來
Microberry
為什麼要反而做 有些人就無力
有些人就喜歡做空
每個人個性不同
好不好
這時候愛你 請問尾川還會長嗎
你們都這樣子跟我撒嬌
Justine
你是男生
尾川也很長
看一下
尾川也有機會
其實這幾天尾川
這現在的現行裡面是尾川最漂亮
我看周顯得
對阿,尾串還突破力行高,是不是?
對阿
所以尾串的現形其實突然間拉起來
尾串很漂亮,尾串
你現在如果用看現形的話
鴻海的線圖比尾串醜很多
三支裡面
三支漁產漂怎麼辦
這個顯露出我的年紀了,扯遠
三支老AI裡面紅海管達尾串
尾串現在線型最漂亮
來 管達
那 25是聯發科 你注意這樣子
今天這個是很大的一空
所以我本來想買它 我現在想想算了
沒想到聯發科的轉型的TPU晶片
很容易被人家取代
我跟你講 那我問一件事
這些外資分析師 哪一個在1000多元
1430元 那附近我是叫你紅海換台積電
台積電換年發科有沒有
回答有 我在跟你們解盤
1400多1500元的時候有沒有
這些外資分析是等到4970的時候
才跟你講 看我年發科是幹嘛
為什麼不賺這一段
你看我為什麼 我就喜歡買低機器
你們現在國劇我就喜歡買它
大不了少賺一點
連南亞可我去賣掉他,反正我賺錢大不了少賺一點,我不在乎啊
是不是今天要有人新聞出來啊?我就說最近為什麼,你看趙建民也好,九妹也好出事
你那對方新聞區的,錢也委屈啊,人家覺得兩才兩失,你新聞區算你錢也委屈
如果你分手的時候,我給你一個兩百萬,我給你一個三百萬對不起你
正常人也不會報你料啦
是不是 趙建民來 我給你1000萬 成訊給你1000萬
是不是 負得起啦
不行 我分期付款 人家是不是覺得你誠意
調車到我為什麼沒事
錢給的多啊
心裡有沒有委屈 可能委屈啊
錢給多嘛 就是這麼簡單
所以我告訴你 股票也是一樣嘛
留點錢給人家賺嘛
我沒有賣4970 我賣4000塊以上可不可以
可以 留點錢給他賺嘛
人家不要的時候我撿起來嘛
人氣我取,人氣我取,人家不要的我一樣
有,三千才買的,有,都有講
1400多的時候有講,叫台積電換成聯發科
是不是 資金不多啊 是不是中美金貨
你先選一個就好 對對對對 選環球金好了 好不好
對不對 好不好 你們不要那麼多壓細金
壓個30%就好了 好不好
群聯為什麼一直開高走低
我不知道 市場好像不太喜歡他們老闆一直講話是不是
怎麼樣 我不知道 有有
怎麼看貝森特就沒債 來來來
貝森特就沒債 我不要跟你重播 來來 我先跟你講
講得你又起雞皮疙瘩
我昨天在這張圖你有沒印象
我說你不要拿2007年比
2007年看起來好像都是
2007年的每在直率都是5.3下
2007年進入海峽
從9300年就跌到3955點
從2008年的5月20號
9300年就跌到2008年
11月21號的3955點
如屬家貞 因為那時候我很痛苦
這跟大家講 也謝謝那一家公司
那時候那菜兩分一時 不給我機會
還有我現在越來越強大 真的是
不給我機會就file這車 我很謝謝他
我不是酸 我是真的
反而讓我覺得人生命很短 你知道嗎
那段時間反而自己做股票還賺比較多
來,休息一陣子,休息很長
30年期美債直率,我扯遠了
聽到一下,他是不是很遠嗎?很慘嗎?
那時候美債是美債直率率,這是費的利率
你看,那時候美債直率率是怎麼那麼高?
因為不得不高,因為我基準的利率
費的利率就那麼高,我不可能比他少
我比他少誰要買我?
費的利率就這樣,我就去存定存就好
幹嘛買美債?所以費的利率就這麼高
我每在直率高也,我每在直率率要更高一點點,很正常
可是現在我費得利率3.63,這麼低,我每在直率這麼高,我說這兩個不一樣
你知道為什麼這兩個不一樣?今天檔案為什麼這兩個不一樣?
一不同,我昨天忘記舉例子那種時候,這兩個不一樣為什麼一不同?
這只有你這樣講有道理,可是又沒道理
以前重點是每在直率都是5.3都會影響資金
你不要硬扯什麼費得利率是一個5.25,現在是3.63
重點是美債子率都是5.3
那資金會吸引過去
重新定價
你看很多網紅可以講重新定價
然後資金被吸走 你有講
為什麼費得利率
以前差距不大 現在差距很大
代表跌就補沒問題
來答案出來了
今天做什麼事
他買了41元
在什麼?美債
然後告訴你邏輯
聽懂的你就會變聰明,你就會覺得我很聰明
我問你一件事,他買41美債
買長期的,賣短期的
我買了以後是不是
我跟你講過,直率跟債券價格是不是相反
我把他買了以後對不對
是不是價格完善了?我一直買他
我買了美國債券,我一直買把價格拱上去
再進直率是不是下滑
資金成本是不是下滑了
沒有5.3的可能到5.1了
這個時候是不是股市的資金就會進來了
我那時候是每在直率一直很高
我現在利用我一直收購
把每在直率價格下滑
把每在直率給打下去
把價格往上提高
把整個人在直率下滑
我那時候說每在直率不能再高
把他打下去了
對不對 他做這件事情
聽我講
來喔 在聽這段
你會覺得很恐怖,講在前面
你覺得如果是2007年的時候,
用這一招有辦法嗎?
這邊是美債,這邊是直率有辦法
打不下去,為什麼打不下去?
你怎麼打?我美債直率就是要比費的利率高
我打不下去,我打到5.1幹嘛?
那時候費的利率那麼高,我去存定存就好了
懂嗎?那現在為什麼說現在跟以前不一樣
因為以前差距不大
每載直率是5.29
費得利率這些定存的利率基準就是5.25
兩個差距不大
我就算是要把它直率打下去
每載直率打下去頂多打到5.25附近
差不多了打不下去
可是我現在費得利率定存利率可能就這邊附近
5.3.63
我5.3.63有差了1.7%
我可以把它打下去
我用買的就可以把它打下去
以前差距不多
我的基準的這邊你只能比我高
你不能比我高我去犯定存就好了
現在差那麼多所以可以打得下去
有沒有分析師可以講這個
沒有啊他們不懂
我都不知道錯的
這在種種機裡看你往後背一些東西
有時候採金的東西
有沒有分析師可以解決這段
一個都沒有
這段很精采
這個你經常財經相關都去佩服著這
有沒有聽到?聽到?聽到按個讚吧
好不好?他一點七可以玩
對沒有錯 懂不懂?變聰明的聽到
那打下去他們懂不懂?變聰明的你們聰明的
你們比金比人的
好不好?那我看吹了
看什麼節目?看我節目
我雖然節目有時候30%在臭屁自己
70%沒有別的節目可以講這些東西
好不好?學到是不是?
OK
來提前分析你們到
OK 現在你很強 你都沒講
總體經濟學的觀念很強
謝謝大家
內容顯示你一樣的
真的懂我的人的
就知道我很猛 好不好?
上面大大說
我感覺主力有跟著的國家對做
你要我說實話嗎?
去年我覺得比較有主力過對做
今天沒有 今天還好
他們可以後來發現很多的數算案件後發現
我是清牌的 我真的不會跟其他組織配合
可能大家覺得比較喜歡用股票
去年感覺好像有人一直跟我們對做股票
今年我覺得還好 真的還好
基隆反而覺得很多人幫我拉股票 信他們
基隆學到東西
Gate那段很重要 題目短沒關係
就是反正有很多空間可以把職業打下去
好嗎?這樣幾分?
我們來講五票了
全年剛剛有講莊美金、寬宇金
來來來,兩個都可以買啦
OK嗎?
好不好?
我要喜歡寬宇金
你一直要買低價股就買莊美金
好不好?
市長都會拉起來了好不好?
我認為市長都會拉起來
好不好?
我們節目很專業
真的我今天講很多
你看預告啊
那個我告訴你賣隔離的邏輯錯誤
還起早預告今天驗證
然後為什麼能力可以利用AI長命百歲
我會深入潛出
第三個 為什麼同樣都是5.3%的
美國30年期公開子綠
為什麼這一次跟2007年不一樣
你拿2007年會崩盤
所以現在會崩盤
出差很多 因為基準利率不一樣
因為基準利率不一樣
所以他基準利率不一樣
差別差很多
所以他有空間打下去
有1.7%的空間打下去
有分析師朋友講一個嗎
他們都看新聞
哇 影響到了
說話成
為什麼
為什麼可以輕鬆影響到
這個真的很恐怖喔 我自己覺得很屌啦
我不是這樣你覺得有沒有覺得
真的真的好不好 最近我覺得太無聊
因為最近太多專業你知道嗎
我比較喜歡搞笑啦
給責愛你一次的機會
這你們還要比較記得 比較喜歡
每天沒有那麼多梗啦
其實我已經蠻多梗啦
今天總經很多東西啦好不好
他什麼東西要講 雅雅科群年愛不
我們看一下差不多啦 剛才有人說資源
資源就先要死不活啦好不好
他也跌不下去 因為之前也沒有漲很多
我都選都沒有漲很多的股票
都漲差不多了 國劇
被動員建我覺得不錯 我會來救他們
遲早會拉起來的
台灣50,0050拉回來是可以買
我們還是賺1000多萬 是不是
1200還是1300 我不知道
這跟大家講 1100 反正有賺錢就對了
應該要賺1000萬
我們看一下 精彩 這個就是感覺
精彩裡面的大戶是真的蠻那個
我不知道為什麼要完成這樣子
這樣子人家不太敢追
我不知道他們看我的節目
我覺得要鎖展庭鎖展庭不要好像做價差
可是看得出來他就是最後要拉起來
精彩從來已經被人家鎖定了
裡面至少裡面的一個大戶就是要鎖定他
我就至少會上去
我認為這些股票你不要單一重壓股票
不要單一重壓的話基本上我的股票
我認為很多股票大多數都會上去
好吧 我愛你們 沒問題 沒問題 結束了
則是國寶 謝謝大家好
台股參加要變少影響 當然變少影響
很多股票很難拉起來 好不好
來來 聯益可以買嗎
那種CPU的題材我覺得有點
我覺得有點那是中思無道 會不會拉
跟那些生機股也是一樣
沒有內心消息怎麼買 我又沒內心消息
我們每次在節目上說 我不跟主力票
你覺得那些主力會來找我嗎
我政教所法院黃永公道不起訴
不是不起訴 今天你知道有個人罵羅志先
說羅志先A他的錢 就是幫他刷卡
幫他刷卡你知道嗎
然後檢察官還不起訴說
就類似說他不明其妙
就某個人覺得被盜刷是幹嘛硬要刷我信用卡
覺得是統一集團害的害他
檢察官還是給他不起訴還有不起訴書
那是一個檢察官的措施
別人搞個自救會 搞一群人告過者
所以我跟主力配合 還去證交所 調資料
還配動用關係 警政署搞成動用關係
那個分析師我是在幹什麼
結果郭忠不是不起訴而已 直接簽截
那兩個檢察官覺得都沒事
連不起訴書都不用寫
根本就是無理群 他懂不懂
OK嗎?這誠信真的是,謝謝他們幫我打廣告
莫名其妙提告,還有不起入書,我連不起入書都不用了
都不用寫了,完全就是覺得莫名其妙,懂不懂
來,先跟大世界重點上去,來看一下世界好不好
現在多少?47,我今天好,還有流汗
50了,結束了,愛你們,愛你們,好不好
今天愛你們好不好,台政科哲學,好不好
台政科一樣好不好,台政科一樣,一起看好不好
你不要每天一天跌就好
台正哥因為我很少人買
我就不講這個東西的好不好
不要把重心發生
今天直播人數7000多人
今天很多東西
我講AI的這個長壽跟莫德納疫苗
祝他產品百歲 接近看看
真的我愛你們
真的我希望你們看更新
還有工債那東西總體經濟
你記得一件事好不好
為什麼跟2007年差很多
我這個很精彩
你就知道我跟其他分析差了
為什麼差不多
去想想看兩者的分析師
對股票再回測
是不是要回測第二隻腳
那不重要 有回測就要買
所以歡迎人家去下旬08068085
或者叫來私訊我
說實實我要查會員
我捷徑我所能
不論對我錯
我一切一切遇到在前面
我可以捷徑我所能來
最盡最大努力來幫你賺大錢
我愛你們 拜拜